James Baldwin is widely considered one
of the most influential writers and
social critics of the 20th century there
has been a recent revival of interest in
his work in part because of the
oscar-nominated film I am NOT your negro
this year marks 30 years since Baldwin's
death but in the last 12 months as book
sales have increased by a remarkable 110
percent now the public can view a rare
collection of Baldwin's work at the
Schomburg Center for research in black
culture in New York City's Harlem
neighborhood the center's director gave
us a look this is James Baldwin's
account of his learning of Martin Luther
King Junior's death when we announced
that we acquired the ball in papers and
an event people were just blown away and
people been just coming through the door
is really fascinated and interested in
Baldwin old and young black and white
all races and colors and orientations
all different folks come out to see what
Baldwin has to say and to connect with
him in a powerful way and I think he's
connected with them because he writes
about their truth he's not with very
great pleasure and a very great sense of
honour that I called mr. James Baldwin
to speak fed to this motion one of my
favorite speeches of Baldwin's is when
he was debating William Cambridge and he
got up there and he spoke about race and
in the moment you are born since you
don't know any better
every sticking stone and every face is
white and since you have not yet seen a
mirror you suppose that you are to just
open his mouth and change the world it
comes as a great shock to discover the
Gary Cooper killing off the Indians when
you were rooting for Gary Cooper but the
Indians were you Baldwin did an essay
which eventually became part of the fire
next time the book in The New Yorker in
1962 and I read it and I was very moved
by it and I asked Life magazine where I
had just started doing freelance work if
I could do
a photo essay on Baldwin they agreed and
he agreed and then for the next month in
January 1963 we traveled throughout the
south I was also struck seeing Steve
Shapiro's photographs the way that he
captured Baldwin in some of the intimate
moments we have come to know like him
dancing in the living room or him sort
of alone or him with a homeless child's
very powerful images that I think strike
us today as how we know Baldwin besides
his writing it even beyond the images
that we saw the people that we met the
leaders and just the whole spirit of the
South at that particular time I think
it's his personality that comes through
I think is it the way he spoke to people
and how he really got to their hearts it
is a matter of changing the attitudes of
this country Martin Luther King is a
great and heroic man but he cannot do
for you what only you can do I think it
more people are coming to know him and I
think more people are coming to know him
because history repeats itself and we're
living in a time that in a lot of ways
Baldwin was living through
[Music]
you see black lives matter you see a
sign from Steve Shapiro's images from
the civil rights movement this is stop
police killings
it could be yesterday and that really
connection of Baldwin's civil rights
activity his writing about race is
really relevant because we're thinking
and and trying to contend with race
still very much the same ways that
Baldwin was a collector's edition of
James Baldwin the fire next time
featuring photos by Steve Shapiro is on
sale right now I never ever got a chance
to meet him but Maya Angelou knew him
well and used to always tell great
stories about him I'd love to see the
debate with Bill Buckley yeah damage yes
that would be good